[Music]
pardon me i don't mean to stare but i
think i know you
clap
[Music]
i'm trying to find out the history of
the blonde you've brought along she's a
girl from chicago i used to know
princess from chicago
things aren't always what they seem
lobbied
lots of people pass all the time it's
easy for a negro to pass for white i'm
not sure it'd be so simple for a white
person to pass for color
so you haven't ever thought to what the
other thought of passing no why should i
now i have everything i've ever wanted
this is my husband jambalu does he no
do you dislike negroes mr bellew no no
not at all
i hate them
[Music]
isn't she extraordinarily beautiful
i suppose
you're alive it's perfect have you ever
thought of what you'd do if john found
out i do what i want more than anything
right now i come up here to live
with you
[Music]
you think they'd be satisfied being
white too satisfied being anything
[Music]
for all of us passing for something or
other
[Music]
aren't we
you